sang
sar G
[Música]
Sari
ama
sar G
[Música]
sang
Saran
G
TP
[Música]
budar G
sar
g
[Música]
t
s s
[Música]
nam
tav ambb
[Música]
Perus
igen
[Música]
G
kus
[Música]
G
si per
[Música]
G
G h
[Música]
G
par
M
So
parag par
[Música]
t g t
parag t par
sang
T V
[Música]
paraga
B para
[Música]
par G
T
rag
[Música]
parang
nam T
G
par T par
sang
s Bom
dia então a gente tendo a percorrido os
comentários
de Robert
turman Então a gente vai entrar agora
nas secções do livro né a gente vai
entrar no próprio
livro então a gente percorreu até o
capítulo 4 início do Capítulo 4 agora a
gente vai seguir por pelas sessões do
livro né eu eu queria começar com um
comentário geral assim né que é assim
isso é um pouco
complicado eu acho que as complicações
elas são interessantes a gente
contemplar né porque enfim eh se fazer
um manual como é que eu devo morrer é
coisa muito complicada talvez a morte
não dê certo né E então isso pode ser
até uma coisa interessante a pessoa não
tá não quer morrer aí não ISS é muito
muito complicado morrer isso é muito
complicado então eu eu dizendo isso na
verdade eu
tô brincando um pouco com a própria
complicação né então a gente começa a
olhar por que que
isso é um enfim é um pouco
complicado é um pouco complicado porque
na verdade aqui é uma grande rede que é
como se a gente não precisasse né Assim
como usuário da morte a gente não
precisaria é saber tudo né basta a gente
tomar um certo caminho direção à morte
aquilo pronto tá resolvido né mas aqui
gho pochê oferece muitas diferentes
opções então ele ele essencialmente
mapeia as possibilidades nossas de
quando a gente entra no bardo do morrer
o bardo do morte o Renascer
né como que a gente pode gerar algum
nível de Lucidez e ter algum tipo de
vantagem no meio desse processo né então
ele vai descrevendo os tipos de Visões
quando nós descrevemos as visões na
verdade nós estamos descrevendo os
nossos mundos internos né os nossos
mundos internos conduzem a diferentes
bolhas de realidade e nós olhamos em
volta aquilo parece separado de nós mas
é completamente não dual com a nossa
própria mente mas nós temos experiências
diferentes então então aqui vão nós
vamos passando nós vamos passando pelas
várias experiências diferentes que vão
surgindo não tem nenhum tipo de ilusão
de que são experiências diferentes mesmo
elas são experiências da própria
Obrigado da própria condição da mente da
pessoa né então a pessoa vê o mundo
desse modo ela olha desse modo né então
ela olha desse modo olha de outro modo
olha de outro modo que ele vai
descrevendo também a pessoa podia ter
visto isso mas não viu então ela vê uma
outra coisa ela podia ter visto essa
outra coisa com Lucidez mas não viu
então ela viu uma outra coisa é assim é
isso que a nossa situação no cotidiano
também a gente não vê as coisas com
Lucidez a gente vê uma outra coisa se
engaja numa outra coisa
né então aqui vai ser essa sucessão de
enganos na verdade né Essa sucessão de
engano ela vai progredindo então em cada
engano a gente tem a possibilidade de
acordar e sair daquilo no meio daquele
engano e o guru rimp porcher dá as
instruções como é que a gente faz para
se dar conta daquilo Mas se a gente não
fez aquelas práticas não entende daquilo
olha para aquilo se assusta aí nós nos
nos engajamos em outros procedimentos e
vamos indo que é exatamente o que
acontece na vida da gente assim o tempo
todo né Sim nós estamos no meio de um
bardo é
isso
E aí G po vai explicando indo vai indo e
indo em direção a um renascimento
favorável se tudo der errado a gente
renasce num ambiente humano né Tá certo
se der muito errado né mas aí Gu Poxa
não tá nem considerando isso tá
considerando que a gente Enfim no mínimo
conseguiu fazer em algum momento
prostrações diante de um altar então na
nossa mente quando tudo complica a gente
pensa e o Buda e o altar
e e as práticas os templos a gente volta
a olhar nessa direção né se a gente
tiver isso a gente retorna nessa
condição como nós estamos aqui tudo de
fronte um altar É mais ou menos isso né
então deu certo estamos
aqui
e mas na verdade G vai
sendo a possibilidade de liberação
completa nos vários lugares né assim a
pior circunstância quando a gente não se
deu conta mesmo e Ressurge desse modo
Então esse é o primeiro comentário que
eu queria fazer né E ainda queria
lembrar que nós podemos resumir tudo
ah nessas afirmações do Buda né que
enfim ele atinge a a
extinção eu não morte então isso eu acho
isso assim muito crucial
né Então essa realização é
o ela é o pano de fundo assim de todo
esse ensinamento
né mas essa parte da Extinção ela ela
não fica Clara né então isso eu não eu
não quero fazer aqui não é uma crítica é
uma a gente classifica os ensinamentos
em classes né então por exemplo essa
classe de ensinamentos ela tá dentro de
uma perspectiva que ela tá dando
conselhos para uma
identidade e vai seguir dando conselhos
para essa identidade até o fim Então
essa é uma classe de
ensinamentos por exemplo eh gur pochê
poderia falar sobre a realidade e sobre
a dissolução das delusões sem precisar
dizer então você é isso então você é
aquilo mas aqui é assim nós estamos
o objetivo desse ensinamento é ajudar as
pessoas que estão sentindo pessoas que
estão sentindo que estão andando daqui
para lá de lá para cá entende Esse é o
ponto então eu acho importante que a
gente também Entenda esse ponto né que a
classe do ensinamento essa classe de
ensinamento é
assim
e quando nós olhamos essa classe de
ensinamento isso é numa cer perspectiva
isso fica quase desesperador
assim porque as classes de ensinamento
que aconselham o que que a nossa
identidade deveria fazer é uma classe de
ensinamento que vai precisar migrar para
outra
ainda
né ela vai ter que andar numa outra
direção essa classe de ensinamento é
assim por exemplo nós estamos dentro do
mundo convencional
que surge pra nossa
mente como uma expressão dessa bolha
interna desse conjunto referenciais que
a gente nem percebe que tem que é lá
oitava consciência sétima consciência né
Aí nós estamos dentro disso e nós somos
o piloto da nossa vida nós estamos
andando para cá andando para lá e
querendo dar certo o que que é isso nós
estamos fazendo sempre originação
dependente né na dependência de aspectos
que a gente guarda como cruciais
nós queríamos fazer uma nova um novo
passo que seja coerente com os
anteriores A gente nem pensa em
coerência mas só pensa os outros como a
base do nosso pensamento aí fazer um
outro passo depois um outro passo depois
um outro passo depois um outro passo
infinitamente enquanto nós estamos
fazendo essa viagem infinita que a gente
pensa para aí eu tô indo para onde mesmo
essa parte eu não pergunto eu só penso
eu tenho que fazer mais um passo mais um
passo não consigo ficar parado eu tenho
que fazer sempre mais um
passo Então como é que eu faço isso Em
que direção eu vou eu tô meio eu tô
olhando assim não tô achando muito bom
né como é que eu preciso de um conselho
Alguém tem que me dizer o que que eu
devo fazer então nós estamos nessa
categoria nós ainda pensamos que nós
podemos ter sucesso de algum modo
seguindo passo a passo como um
empreendimento de originação dependente
que nós vamos chegar em algum lugar nós
não vamos chegar em lugar nenhum pessoal
o lugar que nós vamos chegar é extinção
e não morte que não é alguma coisa que
tenha qualquer característica que é como
tá descrito no no prag na paramita né
Nós vamos dissolver a ignorança
mas toda a perspectiva é assim você não
ganhou enquanto tava vivo agora que você
tá morrendo tem muitos problemas então
nós precisamos dar uns conselhos para
você para enfim dar certo a gente ó
agora realmente vai dar certo né É um
pouco assim né Então essa sensação de
que eu tô em algum lugar eu vou dar
certo essa é
a é como se fosse o gancho eu meio hábil
por quê Porque nós estamos ali querendo
dar certo
ainda então tudo bem mas é como se a
gente não tivesse na Perspectiva última
né
Então é assim
e então nós estamos dentro desse dentro
dessa complexidade aí gur po vai dar
para aqueles que querem vencer enfim né
quer escapar do sofrimento encontrar
algum livro de felicidade aí gur poch
ele dá conselhos pra gente reconhecer o
aspecto último Então ele nos leva para
essa direção do aspecto último
mas ele leva dentro uma linguagem de que
tem alguém ali
né quando nós olhamos o livro tibetan
aliás olhamos o a prática de
POA a prática de Poa ela obrigado uhum
Pode ser agora a prática de Poa ela
trabalha com aí nós vamos em direção ao
coração de
amitaba então é como se a gente saísse
das oito consens se fosse para cinco
sabedorias então isso já é uma outra
e uma outra prática Mas por outro lado
essa prática
do de Poa ela não tem nenhuma instrução
dentro é assim você diga p e
Vá então se a pessoa não tiver uma base
obgado Sea não tiver uma base do Pr
paramita ela não consegue avançar
direito nisso também mas se a pessoa
tiver uma base Pode ser que ela
consiga por outro lado tem essa questão
das deidades pacíficas eadas n do
Tantra
Então vai trabar
de inteligências internas do próprio
corpo né então ele vai considerar por
exemplo vocês se Imaginem vocês estão
aqui meditando inspirando e expirando
observando o corpo e observando o corpo
em diferentes momentos e diferentes
circunstâncias etc vocês vão encontrar
diferentes impulsos dentro diferentes
movimentos diferentes inteligências
operando Então nós vamos encontrar 100
deidades pacíficas
eadas essas inteligências que tão que
tão se movimentando elas são
naturalmente elas são
naturalmente presentes e eu vou
considerar que elas são deidades elas
são deidades protetoras há muito tempo
então essa é uma parte interessante
porque a gente pode dizer bom Mas como
deidades sou eu né aí aquilo fica um
pouco estranho assim né porque por
exemplo a pessoa sofre um corte em uma
semana o corte fecha se dá tudo bem
assim né de modo geral Esse é o tempo
assim Mas fechou por causa do mertiolate
do iodo
ou do que que a pessoa passou ali do da
babosa né O que que fez fechar aquilo
não foi nenhum remédio que fez fechar
foi o próprio corpo inteligência do
corpo ela faz fechar aquilo né É assim
então tem uma inteligência digo u Ah tem
uma inteligência aí eu vou localizando
as deidades aí eu tenho eu tenho
alegrias dentro do corpo eu tenho
Sofrimentos eu tenho dores eu tenho as
mais variadas expressões dentro do corpo
que eu vou me dando conta ao longo da
vida só que
essas inteligências todas elas são
protetores elas são protetoras se nós
não tivéssemos essa inteligência a gente
estava liquidado há muito tempo não
tinha menor chance não tinha
simplesmente se desfazer Então essas
inteligências do corpo elas vão mantendo
a vida no corpo
e então eu me Dou conta disso aí eu vejo
que isso não começou comigo meu pai
minha mãe meu pai e a mãe antes e etc
então a gente se dá conta
uau tem deidades protegendo os seres
humanos a
muito muito tempo caso contrário de
seres humanos não estamos nem aqui né
com certeza então eu eu sou um nada
diante dessas deidades todas então nós
trocamos a nossa visão nós ampliamos a
nossa visão nós damos conta que nós
temos muitas deidades E essas deidades
brotam do
quê elas não brotam da minha mente eu
não penso sobre isso não penso e digo
agora bom não sei se curo não curo aqui
não então tudo bem O curo a gente não tá
curando nada Pessoal as deidades estão
curando então do mesmo modo que nós
olhamos as deidades do lado de fora e
reconhecemos os rios as montanhas os
aspectos todos eu posso olhar para
dentro do corpo e ver muitas
deidades então quando Nós entramos num
processo de sofrimento na proximidade da
Morte essas deidades esses protetores
todos eles
alucinam eles vão até o limite da força
deles porque esse é o processo
deles e aí nós nos defrontamos quando a
gente se defronta com isso pode ser que
a gente reconheça as deidades ou não se
eu reconhecer como deidades eu eu fico
deliciado e vejo o aspecto luminoso Mas
se eu não tive a oportunidade de
contemplar isso e reconhecer Esse
aspecto como aspectos luminosos que
independe da vontade da sexta
consciência Mas eles estão operando de
um modo autônomo autônomo
luminoso então eu não tô preparado para
entender Esse aspecto mas como nós na
proximidade no no evento no no
empreendimento da Morte nós vamos nos
defrontar com esses aspectos todos Esse
é o
campo dentro do qual nós vamos nos
movimentar e é dentro desse Campo que
guru roch vai dar os ensinamentos
né é
isso e nós estamos desesperados a nossa
sexta consciência
alucinada para encontrar uma solução e
nos tirar desse
obstáculo ou seja nós queremos continuar
o aspecto de originação dependente de
qualquer jeito
então agora nós vamos começar a
percorrer essa
aventura boa
sorte na verdade essa é uma aventura que
a gente já tá né não quero aqui deixar
ninguém nervoso com isso mas nós já
estamos nessa aventura e aparentemente
não tem nenhum botão que a gente possa
apertar e dizer bom esse essa
brincadeira não gosto eu tô saindo né
não tem
tem uma charge da Mafalda que é assim
pare o mundo eu quero descer né Essa
parte essa parte não não tá incluída
aqui eu acho interessante né a gente não
tem uma consciência Clara de que entrou
por entrou por aqui né a gente não sabe
onde que botão que a gente apertou para
entrar
a gente sabe que tá aqui
dentro como é que a gente faz para não
brincar desse brinquedo que a gente não
tá mais achando bom né como é que é isso
né então o guru roch vai dar a única
saída de
fato então aí nós vamos seguir por essa
parte do Capítulo 4 que é a última parte
do Capítulo 4 que corresponde à
descrição das sões do livro
Hum então nós temos felizmente um
erudito aqui organizado assim olhando
desse modo
distanciado essa obra que gu sentou para
escrever
momento como erá desesperar embora o
texto tenha se transformado mais ou
menos estabelecido ao longo dos séculos
obrigado
parece varar de alguma forma em
diferentes
versões as próprias coleções do livro da
liberação natural geralmente sugerem que
há mais obras no grupo do que as
incluídas em uma edição
específica a coleção mais bem organizada
que encontrei até agora tem o seguinte
índice ordenado de acordo com o alfabeto
indiano os índices de obras referentes à
liberação natural através do
entendimento do profundo
ensinamento liberação natural através da
contemplação das deidades pacíficas e
iradas então
começa que é assim é o o alfabeto na
como tem a b c d e ele resolveu botar o
alfabeto entando bonito k k
g
ch assim que é o as sílabas de
betan é muito bonito isso a prece de
guria dos três corpos búdico da
liberação natural sem abandonar os três
venenos então essa parte se repete né
Sem abandonar os venenos sem abandonar
as ações negativas sem abandonar para aí
não seria melhor abandonando né então
seria assim isso aqui é um aspecto
tântrico é sem
moralidade é do outro lado já ou seja eu
purifico as ações na forma como elas se
apresentam eu não começo mudando as
ações para depois então purificar não
nós purificamos aquilo como tá porque
sansara nervana eles são inseparáveis o
aspecto
deluso positivo é igual ao aspecto
deluso negativo porque são aspectos
delus vios se eu não superar delusão
então não tem solução a que eu não tenho
como abandonar os três venenos eu tô
imerso nisso mas ainda
assim nós aspiramos os três corpos
búdico da liberação natural mesmo que a
gente esteja mergulhado nos três venenos
que são os três animais
né então começa com essa prece então é
uma sucessão de preces o texto é uma
composição de uma sucessão de preces
então depois tem a prece para estado
intermediário da realidade da liberação
natural através do
entendimento Então tem um modo de
surgimento da deidade irada do Estado
intermediário tem a prece de invocação
de ajuda aos budas E bodis
satas aí tem o verso raiz dos seis
estados
intermediários a vem a prece para a
liberação das dificuldades do Estado
intermediário
orientação para estado intermediário da
existência da grande liberação através
do
entendimento liberação pelo uso
liberação natural
dop prece de Refúgio de todos os
terrores do Estado
intermediário prática do Dharma
liberação natural dos instintos
a
homenagens liberação natural das
negatividades e obscurecimento
[Aplausos]
aqui tem obscurecimento mas eu não
consigo corrigir a vasta a vasta coleção
das deidades pacíficas e eadas a
confissão Da liberação
natural liberação natural através da
Visão direta identificando a lucidez
liberação natural através dos sinais
investigando a
morte enganando a morte a liberação
natural do Medo essa parte enganando a
morte eu achei
interessante enganando a morte liberação
natural do medo o ensinamento que revela
a natureza da virtude do vício no no
estado intermediário da
existência a liberação natural no estado
intermediário da
existência método auxiliar das
instruções que ensinam de forma natural
que ensinam a forma natural da virtude e
do vício no estado intermediário da
existência no total são
271 271 folhos impresso na Índia a
partir de shahat Nadara o
grande gás
D no primeiro dia do primeiro mês de
1985 desses 275 fólios nosso texto
principal aqui consiste em tradução de
folhos 108 folhos do texto
principal 108 folos do texto principal e
42 fólios de preces preliminares e
práticas
anexadas os 108 fólios do texto
principal já foram traduzidos duas vezes
primeiro pela equipe de cas dawa sandou
e Evan ventes e depois pela equipe de
chogan trung par e Francesca
fremantle das duas secções incluídas
aqui na parte três a prática do Dharma
liberação natural dos instintos
é
a inédita
que eu vi em português né mas a palavra
em inglês não tá dito em português
inédito em
português então essa parte não tá no no
inglês
Esses foram os nossos tradutores aqui
que introduziram essa
parte a liberação natural através da
visão de a que achei aquilo muito
interessante a prática do dma liberação
natural dos instintos é inédita em
português aí o Robert turman mandou esse
recado para nós assim
né mas eu acho que isso é inédita em
língua ocidental eu acho que é isso que
ele qu
dizer mas não tem nem essa frase né
É É mas em inglês tá isso tá então é
isso traduzida pra língua ocidental Eu
imagino
né a liberação natural através da Visão
direta identificando a Lucidez foi
anteriormente traduzida por Evan vens e
novamente por John Reynolds
uma vez que oferece uma visão sustentada
dos fundamentos filosóficos do livro da
liberação natural eu fiz a sua tradução
do tibetano usando minha terminologia e
interpretação para se encaixar com o
restante da nova tradução ou seja nós
psiconautas das secções
resultantes não traduzidas aqui a sessão
P sobre os sinais da Morte foi traduzida
por G Mulan mulin as outras sões sem
dúvida serão traduzidas no futuro quando
os estudiosos produzirem versões mais
eruditas para a
pesquisa no espírito do Tesouro
original que foi concebido pelo mestre
pad ma sambava como uma ajuda prática
para as pessoas em geral tentei
apresentar uma uma versão popular e prá
do livro da liberação
natural organizei o texto da maneira que
achei mais útil para aqueles que o estão
usando em relação à ocasião real da
Morte seja quando estão se aproximando
de sua própria morte ou quando alguém
próximo está
morrendo coloquei as preces mais
importantes de uma sessão Inicial na
ordem mencionada na sessão preliminar do
Estado intermediário da realidade
pois de acordo com as instruções elas
devem ser recitadas logo no início de
qualquer
maneira em seguida apresento os três
estados intermediários o estado
intermediário do momento da morte da
realidade que é quando a Alucinação
começa e da
existência distinguindo em as
sessões que devem ser lidas em voz alta
na presença do Cido as sessões da
tradução estão organizadas da seguinte
forma primeiro uma sessão preliminar de
preces guria dos três corpos ajuda dos
budas e
bodisatvas liberação das dificuldades do
Estado intermediário Refúgio de todos os
terrores do Estado intermediário versus
raiz dos seis estados
intermediários depois uma manual para os
Estados intermediários que tem os
preliminares o estado intermediário no
momento da morte as deidades pacíficas
do Estado intermediário da realidade as
deidades iradas do Estado intermediário
da realidade e aí o estado intermediário
da
existência depois as traduções
suplementares prática do Dharma
liberação natural dos instintos
liberação natural através da Visão
direta e identificando a
Lucidez super relevante
né então ambas as versões tibetanas
disponíveis para meu trabalho demonstram
certa crueza e falta de
refinamento característica típica de
obras
populares erros de impressão são
frequentes a ortografia é irregular e
por vezes os dois textos diferem em suas
interpretações em pequenos detalhes um
empreendimento acadêmico útil seria
reunir uma um grande número de edições
do livro de liberação natural e preparar
uma edição crítica aqui esse liberação
devia ser com litra maiúscula
né optei por não fazer isso e não
sobrecarregar o texto com notas de
rodapé extensas apresentando as
diferentes interpretações encontradas
nas edições que utilizei os mortos e os
dutados não estão com disposição para
Tais sutilezas acadêmicas tipo pé de
página usei nomes sânscritos para as
deidade sempre que possível utilizando
um sistema de transliteração
foneticamente Óbvio seus nomes foram
Originalmente apresentados em línguas
indianas que os tibetanos traduziram
para o tibetano já que os de tongos e
grupos de consoantes indo-europeus eram
difíceis para eles pronunciar es o
inglês é uma língua indo-europeia e
considera os nomes indianos mais
agradáveis já forneci uma elucidação dos
principais conceitos de base que
acredito serem necessários também
apresenta um comentário ao longo da
tradução diferenciado dela por sua letra
menor termos desconhecidos são anotados
na primeira ocorrência E caso contrário
podem ser consultados no
glossário concluindo esse trabalho
fiquei profundamente tocado pela
preocupação com a
eutanásia entre os doentes terminais e
os idosos na América fica evidente que o
livro da liberação natural Condena o
suicídio a menos que a pessoa já tenha
alcançado a liberação
ou esteja confiante de que pode fazê-lo
no estado
intermediário o suicídio é uma ação
evolutiva negativa de tirar a própria
vida para um praticante tântrico é um
deicídio
seja matar deidades já que o corpo é em
si um corpo de da deidade e a morada de
inúmeras microd
deidades por outro lado as pessoas estão
tentando se tornar menos passivas em
relação ao seu sofrimento tentando
afirmar algum controle sobre suas vidas
afirmando o controle sobre suas
mortes elas estão finalmente
amadurecendo para o fato de que as
autoridades tê conhecimento e capacidade
limitados estão Despertando para o fato
de que a qualidade de vida é mais
importante do que a quantidade bruta de
tempo envolvida e estão corajosamente
tomando suas próprias
decisões lamentavelmente aqueles que se
veem diante de uma doença terminal em
sofrimento Talvez tenham recorrido ao
suicídio ou cogitam fazê-lo
provavelmente creem que a destruição do
próprio cérebro representa a conquista
da liberação instantânea visualizada por
um completo
desaparecimento isso se revelará um
trágico erro de para alguns deles
certamente existem aqueles que são
pessoas habitualmente felizes e alegres
gentis e
generosas capazes de se desapegar sem
muitos problemas que conseguirão
reconhecer a luz mais brilhante e se
fundir com ela apesar da surpresa por
não encontrar o
desaparecimento e mesmo sem uma
preparação formal
mas também haverá aqueles que são mais
tensos e rígidos que tentam Manter o
controle a Qualquer Custo os
capricornianos
taurinos
virginianos mas também há aqueles que
são mais tensos e rígidos que
tentam tentam manter o controlle a todo
custo a menos que tenha uma garantia de
Aniquilação que são muito apegados aos
seus corpos suas Posses suas identidades
seus confortos essas pessoas realmente
sofrerão no turbilhão do Estado
intermediário e terão poucas chances de
sair bem em uma boa posição na roda das
possibilidades e muito menos de alcançar
a liberação
portanto Espero que pelo menos alguma
dessas pessoas os seus entes queridos e
amigos encontrem esse livro esse grande
livro da liberação natural através do
entendimento no estado intermediário e
tentem colocá-lo em prática mesmo que
seja Seguindo a linha da aposta de
Pascal Espero que o trabalho seja
benéfico para
eles se ajudar até mesmo uma pessa
cumprirá o objetivo do mestre padm
sambava e seus colegas e meu esforço
terá valido a
pena que todos os seres sejam abençoados
pelas três joias planeta esteja em paz e
a terra permaneça bela que todos os
seres sejam felizes que todos tenham Boa
Fortuna e agora
nós
começamos o grande livro da liberação
natural através do entendimento do
Estado
intermediário parte do manual para a
jornada coleção completa de a gente
pensa bom agora vai começar começa
comentá de novo
a coleção completa dos textos tesouros
contidos por Padre masamba no Tibete no
século vi depois de Cristo chama-se a
liberação natural por meio da
contemplação dos budas pacíficos eados
entre eles o grande livro da liberação
natural através do entendimento de
estado intermediário inclui o conjunto
de textos que estamos aqui
apresentando ele foi composto por pasm
zambada o grande adep de Diana escrito
por sua consorte y sogia e escondido
como um tesouro ele foi descoberto e
trazido ao mundo na montanha gamb podar
pelo grande descobridor de tesouros kma
limpa ó Isso aqui é uma pequena
introdução aí
começa outra introdução aí começa o
capítulo C né então no capítulo C ele
vai descrever agora as preces do Estado
intermediário Então já estamos começando
as cinco preces versos seguintes são a
espinha dorsal de todo o livro da
liberação natural Então são as preces do
Estado intermediário cinco preces os
versos seguintes são espinha dorsal de
todo o livro da liberação natural eles
são o programa central de todo o
progresso elas devem ser memorizadas e
depois recitadas em diferentes momentos
enquanto são oferecidas as instruções
mais longas
primeiro a guru yoga dos três corpos
fornece uma meditação sobre o processo
de transformação ideal previsto pelo
livro da liberação
natural ideal porque nós vamos
diretamente pro corpo do Buda né dar
sak ele se aproxima desse ideal a
focaliz através da pessoa que seja o
guru espiritual alguém bem conhecido
gerenciado pelo praticante as outras
quatro preces das cinco né formam um
conjunto que é frequentemente referido
ao longo do livro da liberação natural a
prece por ajuda é um apelo em prosa
direcionado às três joias o boda o darme
a sanga Para que estendam sua compaixão
Salvadora a alguém que esteja morrendo
ou no processo do Estado intermediário a
prece para liberação percorre o padrão
das experiências estado intermediário da
realidade rezando para que todos os
elementos da existência comum se
transformem em agentes da
liberação a prece de
refúgio continua suplicando aos seres
iluminados por assistência e
proteção a ênfase não está tanto na
liberação mas no Refúgio ao longo das
vidas futuras está mais relacionado com
a existência intermediária quando é mais
difícil alcançar a liberação completa e
a preocupação é mais com a garantia de
um renascimento
favorável já os versos raiz dos seis
estados intermediários fornecem um
resumo final dos seis estados
intermediários e sua contemplação
transforma todos os ciclos temporais num
veículo para
iluminação se você estiver lendo esse
livro para alguém que está no processo
de morrer ou que já entrou no estado
intermediário Talvez seja melhor ler
agur yoga dos três corpos e a prece por
ajuda para estabelecer um contexto
favorável e depois pular para a prece do
Estado intermediário da realidade
propriamente dita encontramos os versos
individuais das outras preces no
contexto das instruções
Gerais em toda essa sessão da tradução o
texto em negreto indica traduções
diretas que devem ser lidas em voz alta
durante a realização da liberação
natural por alguém nos processos do
morrero e do Estado
intermediário o material em fonte comum
está em dois tamanhos tamanho maior
indica traduções das instruções e
comentários originais do texto do
Tesouro tamanho menor indica
comentários instruções do
tradutor ele começa com o ponto que é o
ponto
principal a prece da guru yoga dos três
corpos aí ele começa com comentário
ainda
inclui inicialmente inclui inicialmente
essa prece Da liberação natural em
particular com o subtítulo liberação
natural sem abandonar os três venenos
ela é a primeira da coleção original e
estabelece de forma mais concisa e bela
o contexto que você precisa para para
usar as liberações naturais
subsequentes a importância do
relacionamento com o guru
pessoal a confian em uma pessoa que
possa representar para você a realidade
e o poder Supremos do
Cosmo
independentemente de como você o
defina não pode ser
subestimada então aqui ele tá trazendo
essa noção absoluto seria o
cosmo a gur yoga é uma meditação de
visualização que invoca a presença do
professor espiritual que lhe iniciou na
Mandala Sagrada correspondente à forma
do Estado búdico escolhida por você uma
vez que a presença tenha sido invocada o
guru é visualizado fundindo em
você de forma fundindo-se com você de
forma indivisível de modo que você se
torna o professor o Buda a
autoridade esse seria o aspecto externo
né o aspecto interno é a pessoa
acessar diretamente essa sabedoria né
Essa aquilo surge Deus de dakia Então
desse lugar o nosso fluxo mental surge
como o
guru o Buda
autoridade Então você envia suação para
todos os eles assim como o guru Buda
concedeu a bênção a você então isso é a
prática de Guru yoga nós
acessamos nós dissolvemos a nossa mente
comum na própria mente do
Buda dito de outro modo nós amadurecemos
a oitava consciência para dar Macaia
então de lá surge
sambakia e neroman caia
como a maioria de nós não foi iniciada
podemos pensar nesse guru como o pad
masan bava o autor do livro da liberação
natural os três corpos de um Buda são a
maneira de pensar sobre o aspecto
inconcebível de um Buda perfeito
expressando a unidade de um ser
iluminado com a realidade última a
bem-aventurança pessoal e a criatividade
das emanações para o benefício dos
outros o guru deve ser visualizado com a
corporificação desses três aspectos da
supremacia para que você cultive um
sentimento de graça quando esver na
presen
Del sentimento de graa é a suprema
benturan eu o quarto dos seis selos né
quarto quinto
o guru deve ser
visualizado no espaço imaginativo do
olho da mente diante de
você sentado em um Trono de joias reais
de proporções divinas cercado por todos
os budas deidades anjos e outros os
anjos são dacas daques né e outros seres
poderosos sábios e amados se seu pessoal
for um ente
querido um
sacerdote uma pessoa Sagrada de qualquer
religião ou um médico curandeiro ou Xamã
visualize-o da mesma
forma então o aspecto grosseiro é a
própria aparência do ser o aspecto Sutil
é a própria sabedoria o aspecto secreto
é dakia é o local livre da mente de onde
Brota a Lucidez que enfim é o
[Música]
guru os três venenos ganância ódio
delusão são os três vícios primários que
impulsionam o ciclo da vida não
iluminado e repleto de Sofrimento a
liberação que ocorre sem eliminá-los é
verdadeiramente
natural a transformação imediata dos
ensinamentos eu diria pela grande
perfeição né o dos Ensinamentos da
grande
perfeição essencialmente é o
reconhecimento de vacuidade e
luminosidade disso né então os próprios
venenos eles deixam de ser critic porque
eles são vistos como um jogo
deluso da
natureza Luminosa da mente
om
Av
om é o som mântrico ou magicamente
criativo ele representa
D eu som um mântrico o magicamente
criativo que ressoa com a unidade
transcendente e portanto é usado no
início dos mantras para evocar a
manifestação do que é transcendente ou
divino Av
k é mais em comum
Av significa vacuidade ou ausência de
identidade fixa em todas as coisas e
portanto sua maleabilidade para a arte
criativa da grande
compaixão
k representa o som a da criatividade
cósmica
emergindo da posição k de início sendo k
a primeira
consoante Ah é o mantra da fala
iluminada fala iluminada Brota de
dakia pra do
h a guru do corpo da verdade não nascido
e que não é
desenvolvido ou seja ele
ele ele não tem uma
evolução e ele é não nascido ou seja
incessantemente presente esse corpo o
guru do corpo da verdade não nascido não
desenvolvido é dar caa grande vacuidade
lúcida no palácio do perfeito e
onipresente reino da
Verdade com sincera devoção ardentemente
eu
rogo autol liberado sem abandonar a
delusão do conhecimento
enganoso ou seja as aparências todas
elas podem seguir nos vários mundos
múltiplos
mundos seria a sabedoria do espelho n
então sem abandonar a delusão do
conhecimento enganoso recebo
espontaneamente a perfeita bênção do
corpo da verdade como sendo a sabedoria
primordial não fabricada e sem
esforço aqui pessoal isso equivale a a
iniciação de
dmac aqui você se concentra na
de seu
guru com a realidade
absoluta Então essas palavras elas
correspondem à iniciação de dar
Macaia se a pessoa vê ela recebeu a
iniciação se ela não ver ela recebeu as
palavras aqui você se concentra na
unidade então agora é sambakia aqui
então ele explica né aqui você se
concentra na unidade de seu guru com a
realidade absoluta percebendo-se unido a
essa realidade através de sua
presença então a presença do guru dá ela
como que aciona dentro de nós a
capacidade de Lucidez de ver as coisas
como elas são no instante em que você se
lembra da infinitude da realidade
absoluta sente ou seja o aspecto
infinito da realidade absoluta que
abrange todas as coisas sente uma
inundação avassaladora de graça que é a
suprema bem-aventurança da sua própria
insara com a realidade absoluta
reconhecendo que é impossível que alguma
coisa tenha deixado de estar unida a sua
presença absolutamente infinita
você se sente instantaneamente
livre e até mesmo o vício mental da
delusão se transforma naturalmente na
sensação da presença do
absoluto sem precisar mais ser
abandonado você visualiza um
R de Safira Azul profundo e cintilante
no coração de seu
guru ele irradia uma luz azul Safira que
entra no centro de seu
coração e o preenche com a sabedoria
dinâmica da
liberdade então a sabedoria da liberdade
que a dinâmica ela não tá
fixada essa sequência de
visualização está associada ao
recebimento
da
iniciação da sabedoria da
intuição a prática do estágio da
perfeição a transparência da Clara luz
ao momento da morte a mente e ao corpo
da
verdade então aqui nós acessamos
sambakia nós temos essas palavras elas
vão nos conduzir à iniciação
da de samb bog
caia Então as palavras são assim ao
corpo ao guru do corpo da beatitude
Imortal e de grande bem-aventurança no
palácio da bem-aventurança Universal da
sabedoria pura e brilhante com sincera
devoção ardentemente eu
rogo autol liberado sem abandonar a
Luxúria o desejo recebo
espontaneamente a bênção sem esforço do
corpo da beatitude como sendo a
liberação natural da sabedoria interna
bem-aventurada Então a nossa mente comum
ela ela é dita comum porque ela opera a
partir de referenciais
ah construídos quando a mente opera a
partir da natureza livre ela não é mais
vista Como Uma Mente comum ela se torna
a mente da grande bem-aventurança que é
sambakia agora ele vai descrever
primeiro ele comenta né o corpo
Ah o corpo de nação que a nirman cai é o
corpo grosseiro que ele deixa de ser um
corpo grosseiro porque ele se torna o
corpo de um Buda então ele não é mais um
corpo grosseiro ele tá operando a partir
da sabedoria que
a Ah
sambakia e a sabedoria sambakia a partir
opera a partir da maturidade da oitava
consensa
enquanto DM caia é a oitava consciência
Deixa de ser alaia Virgin Nana e se
transforma dakia
né então agora ele vai descrever o o a
manifestação do guru num corpo grosseiro
ou a nossa manifestação como um guru num
corpo grosseiro concentre-se no
sentimento incessante de bem-aventurança
beatífica de seu
percebendo o olhar sorridente amoroso
dele sobre
você
instantaneamente você se sente inundado
da mesma alegria e
bem-aventurança da sua da unidade do seu
guru com o
absoluto articulada com a sua própria
Liberdade felicidad
individuais livre de qualquer agitação
de luxúria ou desejo por uma suposta
felicidade fora de
você Você visualiza um a vermelho rubi
brilhante no centro da garganta de seu
guru irradiando raios brilhantes de luz
rbi esses raios brilham sobre você e
entram em seu próprio centro da
garganta abençoando sua fala com uma
sabedoria iluminada e
flutuante essa visualização está
associada ao recebimento da iniciação
secreta a obtenção do corpo
mágico ao estado intermediário a fala e
ao corpo da
beatitude então o nosso corpo comum ele
transforma no corpo
mágico e aqui estão as palavras do texto
que fazem essa transição
ao guru do corpo de uma nação inefável e
autoc criado no palácio do lótus
perfeito e
imaculado com sincera devoção
ardentemente eu
rogo autol liberado sem abandonar o ódio
enganoso recebo espontaneamente a bênção
sem esforço do corpo de emanação
como uma auto iluminação
introspectiva da sabedoria
naturalmente
manifesta aqui você se concentra na arte
ilimitadamente criativa de seu
guru de emanar corporifica ativas de
iluminação para interagir
compassivamente com outros
seres
instantaneamente você sente a parceria
da atividade do cla do
lótus
de manifestar corporifica distintas da
arte da
liberação livre de qualquer agitação ou
irritação com a feiura a intrat
abilidade das formas de vida você
visualiza um h de Diamante brilhante no
centro da coroa do
guru irradiando raios deslumbrantes de
luz branca que preenchem seu próprio
centro
cerebral essa
visualização está associada ao
recebimento da iniciação do vaso a
prática do estágio da geração a vida ao
corpo e ao corpo de
emanação Aos três corpos do bururu que é
imparcial e de grande
bem-aventurança no palácio da autêntica
introspecção da Clara
Luz ou seja todas as aparências
com sincera devoção ardentemente ao rogo
autol liberada sem abandonar o dualismo
de sujeito e
objeto por quê Porque ele não ele não
não rejeita o dualismo por quê Porque
ele libera o a o dualismo então o
dualismo ele é uma manifestação Luminosa
da própria mente então Portanto ele não
precisa abandonar o dualismo enquanto
uma existência então autol liberado sem
abandonar o dualismo de sujeito e objeto
recebo espontaneamente a bênção da
grande bem-aventurança dos três corpos
Então essa aqui é a parte final então
ele primeiro recebeu de um dois três
agora ele recebe dos três como a
espontaneidade da
sabedoria como a espontaneidade da
sabedoria original dos três corpos aqui
é como se fosse então zab vi cacaia que
é a união dos três corpos né então
dakia eu posso imaginar que há algo não
nominado que vai surgir como dakia
sambakia nerman caia então Esse aspecto
não nominado ele é a base dos três
corpos
e a base dos três corpos aqui é descrita
como na última linha como a
espontaneidade da sabedoria original dos
três
corpos aqui você se concentra no guru em
si mesmo tornando-se ind indivisivel
fundido com os corpos
absolutos corp os corpos absoluto de
beatitude de emanação da
iluminação na espontaneidade da grande
perfeição instantaneamente você se sente
completo e perfeito dentro de si mesmo
integrando a infinidade do Bud vero
dentro de você livre de qualquer senso
de dualidade sobre si mesmo e sobre
qualquer universo externo e
objetivo Você visualiza luzes de
Diamante r e Safira que são diferentes
cores né irradiando
omrom então luz branca vermelha e azul
no centros da coroa da garganta e do
coração do guru e preenchendo seus três
centros com luz branca vermelha e azuis
e
bem-aventurança em seguida o guru se
dissolve em raios de luz que se fundem
em
você e você e seu
guru se tornam Um só e o mesmo ou seja
nunca houve separação de fato então
agora isso é visto né Essa visualização
está associada ao recebimento da quarta
iniciação a realização do estágio de
integração a prática da grande perfeição
ao estado intermediário iluminado da
morte da vida indivisível da
realidade A indivisibilidade entre o
corpo fala mente e a indivisibilidade
dos três corpos então indivisibilidade
do corpo fala em mente do corpo fal
mente são as três iniciações e a
indivisibilidade dos três em conjunto é
iniciação
ó compaixão por esses seres conscientes
e sofredores que vagueiam no ciclo da
vida obscurecidos por delusões sem
conhecer suas próprias mentes como o
infinito corpo da verdade que todos eles
ajam o corpo da
Verdade agora você mesmo se tornou guru
e portanto não precisa mais de nenhuma
bênção ou graça para si
mesmo se a pessoa efetivamente tomou a
iniciação E isso aconteceu ela então ela
tem essa mente inseparável do gro
primordial você olha para o campo
infinito de seres em sua mente vendo-os
olhar para você em busca de ajuda e
felicidade antes de mais nada você vê
através deles como se fosse um só com a
transparência Infinita da realidade
absoluta o um da cor de safira azul
escura no centro de seu
coração explode suavemente como uma luz
azul
Radiante que brilha no coração deles
fazendo com que eles também se sintam
Unidos a essa realidade
absoluta a felicidade que eles sentem ao
receber essa bênção se irradia de volta
para o um com mais luz azul tornando-se
cada vez mais inesgotavel
poderoso
ó compaixão por esses seres conscientes
desorientados por seus desejos que
vagueiam no ciclo da vida
identificando-se com Luxúria e apego sem
conhecer sua autoconsciência como a
suprema
bem-aventurança do corpo da
beatitude que todos eles alcancem o
corpo da
beatitude agora você o guru olha
novamente para o Campo infinito de seres
em sua mente vendo-os olhar para você em
busca de ajuda e
felicidade você percebe a felicidade
deles por se sentirem Unidos com a
transparência Infinita da realidade
absoluta
ou
a vermelho rubi brilhante no centro de
sua garganta explode suavemente com uma
luz vermelha Radiante que brilha em suas
gargantas intensificando ainda mais a
felicidade deles de modo que eles
transbordam para o impulso de expressar
sua
beatitude essa bem-aventurança gera
infinitas expressões poéticas de amor e
alegria que envi mais raios de luz Rubi
de volta ao a em sua garganta tornando
cada vez mais inesgotavel
poderoso
ó compaixão por esses seres equivocados
que vagueiam no ciclo da vida com a
mente dualista do ódio então ele passou
pelos três venenos né sem conhecer suas
próprias mentes como corpo de emanação
livre de nascimento que todos eles
alcancem o corpo da
emanação agora você o guru olha para o
campo infinito de seres com seu olho da
mente vendo-os olhar para você em Êxtase
crescente você percebe que a felicidade
deles flui para os infinitos outros
seres que se sentem excluídos à grande
perfeição da realidade o om Branco
Diamantino no centro de sua coroa
explode suavemente com a luz branca
diante que irradia na das coroas nas
coroas deles intensificando ainda mais a
bem-aventurança de modo que eles
transbordam com o impulso de se emanarem
em formas físicas que podem interagir
com infinitos seres
alienados os infinitos corpos de
emanação fluem da rede de Raios de luz
de de diamante interagindo com infinitos
seres agradando os e
libertando-os a felicidade o alívio
deles retorna em forma de mais luz
branca tornando a sua luz om de Diamante
ainda mais inesgotavel
poderosa
[Aplausos]
ó compaixão por todos os seres que ainda
não são budas aprisionados pelo hábito
presença de véus viciantes e
objetivos sem conhecer suas próprias
mentes como os três corpos indivisíveis
que todos eles possam alcar os três
corpos do Estado búdico Então vem agora
a quarta
[Música]
iniciação agora você o guru olha para o
campo infinito de seres em sua mente
vendo-os olhar para você em infinita
felicidade Inter
penetrante você percebe que a felicidade
deles está integrada ao senso de unidade
com você ou com todos os seres na
realidade
absoluta os raios de bênção deles em
direção a você tornam-se tão
infinitamente poderosos Quanto os seus
raios em direção a
[Música]
eles você sente a bem-aventurança
infinitamente expansiva da interpenetra
com eles que parece uma radiância
multifocal de Raios de luz azul vermelha
e branca girando infinitamente em torno
da comunhão infinita de todos vocês
tornando-se
om o corpo a fala e a mente de todos os
seres
iluminados vocês celebram o aspecto
inconcebível da Integração perfeita
da sua unidade primordial não nascida
azul
escura da sua habilidade comunicadora
vermelha escura e e toda abrangente e da
sua manifestação
individual
interflet branca como
Diamante o hábito presença é o nível
mais profundo da conceitualização equiv
Ou seja a sensação da pessoa existir né
que enfim ele tá falando PR as pessoas
que sentem que existem né e mas ele tá
explicando aqui que esse o hábito
presença é o nível mais profundo da
conceitualização equivocada que mantém a
sensação de estar aqui agora como algo e
alguém finito separado do inconcebível
Buda Primor
servindo de base para instintos
viciantes e objetivos de autopreservação
e bloqueando a consciência da sabedoria
primordial
bem-aventurada indivisível da realidade
eterna da
iluminação Então as quatro iniciações
tem para casa olhar isso de novo de
no então nós vamos parar nesse ponto
aqui pessoal só isso já resolveu
tudo mas como a gente passa por isso e
não vê então precisa da prece pela ajuda
dos budas E bodat então agora é como
se tivesse nos colocado lá em cima do
poste aí nós começamos a descer né e
assim ele vai
ajudando em diferentes momentos dessa
experiência cada mais grosseira e
confusa Então nós vamos agora fazer a
prática de Poa hoje nós vamos fazer uma
prática de Poa curta e de novo a gente
vai tornando isso mais complexo mais
complexo Então hoje nós
vamos fazer a prece
Inicial e vamos até a primeira recitação
do
refrão aí depois nós vamos página 15 e
encerramos e amanhã a gente
começa a olhar de forma mais
complexa adicionando as outras
partes a gente vai começar com refúgio
[Música]
so
ess esse agregado ilusório que o apego
considera ser eu transforma-se através
da meditação na deidade da grande
compaixão quando nós olhamos isso P
gente pode dizer criando coisas mas essa
realidade ela é criada também então já
estamos nessa interface a gente já sabe
que a realidade aqui é criada então a
gente desloca para uma outra direção
então a gente cria essa a gente se
transforma na na deidade da grande
compaixão tieren Zig acendendo a partir
do coração está o canal central de
Sabedoria acima de minha cabeça no
espaço aberto da terra da grande
bem-aventurança está o Buda meaba melhor
doss guias cercado por budas e bistas
compassivos e amorosos no centro da flor
de lottos de oito pétalas no coração as
oito
consciências
purificadas minha consciência na forma
de um ovo de pássaro masal um tigle a
minha
tigle
um objeto no qual ah
o meu foco inteiro
Ah se
concentra Então minha consciência né
focada num ponto que eu vou descrever
como ovo de pássaro masal repousa sobre
um brilho
cintilante ela se projeta para cima
tornando-se uma una com a mente coração
de amaba
per
s
[Música]
theu
inelo a
vamos a página 15 da
sadana então o corpo do protetor
amitaba dissolvendo-se em Luz funde-se
comigo e me transforme aos emanando luz
e acumulando a essência da vida que se
dissolve em mim uma Maran de venta uma
de
venta de
Vent uma de
[Música]
magnífico Bud miaba tendo a sua direita
o senhor da grande compaixão ten resig a
sua esquerda o ser de grandioso poder
vagir Pani cercado por um secto
incontável de budas e
budistas na maravilhosa infinita
felicidade da terra pura conhecida como
grande
bem-aventurança possamos eu e os demais
após Termos Nos transferido dessa vida s
a interposição de outros Nascimentos
Renascer e contemplar a face de amitaba
pela força dessa minha aspiração rogo
para que todos os budas e Bod statuas
das 10 direções possam conceder sem
obstáculos a bênção da realização e
P
[Música]
adrial quaisquer raízes de virtude que
eu tenha acumulada aqui ao longo dos
três tempos dedico os para que todos os
seres alcancem o estado búdico que eles
possam alcançar os trê caias o estado de
Total
Liberdade que os mos desse encontro se
expandam e toquem a todos que o Mestre
Universal da Paz e da compaixão sua
santidade da lail Lama juntamente com
todos os mestres de todas as tradições
que veiculam essa mensagem Tenha longa
vida que todos estejam a salvo de gerar
pensamentos negativos o obstáculo mais
destrutivo que esses pensamentos nunca
surgem nossa mente e que todos os seres
também estejam livres de pensamentos
negativos ao longo de minhas muitas
vidas e até este momento todas as
virtudes que tem
alcançado gerados por esta prática e
todas as que vieram a conseguir ofereço
para o bem-estar dos seres scientes
possam a doença guerra fome sofrimento
diminui para todos os seres Enquanto sua
sabedoria e compaixão aumentam nesta em
vidas futuras possa eu
claramente todas as experiências como
sendo tão insubstanciais quanto tecero
do sonho durante a noite é imediatamente
despertar para perceber a manifestação
de Sabedoria pura no surgir de cada
fenômeno possa eu rapidamente alcançar a
iluminação para trabalhar sem cessar
pela liberação de todos os seres budas e
bodas em conjunto seja qual for a sua
motivação sua ação benéfica e preces
auspiciosas seja qual for a sua
onisciência
realizações e poderes benévolos e seja
qual for a sua imensa
sabedoria que igualmente venho para
beneficiar os seres
rogo para que possa alcançar as mesmas
qualidades neste exato momento possam
nem mesmos nomes doença fome guerra e
sofrimento ser ouvidos pelas pessoas e
nações da terra mas possam sim sua
conduta moral mérito riqueza e
prosperidade crescer e possam a suprema
bem-aventurança e bem-estar sempre
surgir
parair ao ego
Kan
[Música]
V
Obrigado
pessoal
obrigado noite
Bom dia pessoal bom dia gente sanga bom
diaa bom dia sanga bom dia bom dia
gratidão gratidão